the Joe Rogan experience and everybody
saying there Frank Sinatra again yeah
get it see if I get this signature all
over the place oh really yeah oh yeah I
put my I put my seen it down by 20 times
I've been about eight times it's a great
player
Watson temptations down here oh wow
temptations Frankie Lymon and the
teenagers but beautiful beautiful police
oh the other place torn down the Olympia
Stadium where they used to play the
scene in a piston used to play
basketball there they are they tore that
place now I saw I was presently there
Elvis Presley oh look here and that's
all Elvis I always wanted to go to see
the Cronk gym but I think they tore that
down is a basketball that krunk's gym
really he seems to be used to be a
basketball court there then they tore it
might've torn it down now
but they had they built boxing rings
around it so all the box will be play
ball they've got boxing around that we
went up they went David my shoes what
the hell happened they then closed the
doors and everything turning to turn
into boxing now make great boxers what's
a Tommy Hearns and then people came out
of the shore Lennox Lewis
managed Stewart was a head coach Sarah
before it so he died yeah that wasn't a
amazing gym but it was white one of
those places is a few places or you want
to go like when you're in LA you want to
go to a wild-card
you just want you to say you've been
there I want to go to the cage where you
are you coming the time anytime you want
to go in California on screen like this
we get you pretty close
you got the [ __ ] out really serious
about that have you ever gone to one of
them live no no never
oh yeah let's hook that up funny
you should film them I'll be like so
what do you feel is about the fight
almost set up a tripod in front of them
oh my god just react or something oh
yeah I love it when they do little thing
on their background they do hmm piece on
the background what's written woofing
woofing
oh he tell me what whatever whenever I
flip your ass I want your wife to come
over clean my house I'm like I wanted I
wanted to come and cook me a meal she
cook anything I wanted to cook me this
guy was Brazilian the guy that pony's
involved man come on man let's play and
let's fight and you ain't gotta talk
about my wife and stuff man you don't
tell me what to do Italian is somebody
else on this is name there's a weak
resilient is Anderson Silva oh yeah yeah
yeah he's old and what guys oh he's
about 43 right Anderson Anderson's 40
chill might be a little older than that
yeah yeah Anderson's greatest
middleweight of all time yeah are you
talking about the one who his angle snap
do you talk about that one I tell my
song about kickin this and that's like
this and it's like dead what did I did
fell asleep I think you're thinking of a
different fight now I thinking of Vitor
yeah that's the front kick to the face
one that's like a legendary kick the
other one who's Chael Sonnen the Chael
Sonnen one he he kicked him and he
dropped him then he need him to the body
and took him out with punches
[Applause]